we have five statements listed here and
your goal is to determine which of these
five statements are true and it might be
more than one or it might be none of
them at all
so let's go through these statements one
by one the first one is that mass and
weight are the same thing this is
absolutely false this is not true mass
you could view it as a measure of how
much matter there is in an object how
much stuff there's an object or how
resistant that object is to acceleration
you could view it as a measure of
inertia while weight is the force of
gravity on that object so weight is
actually a force so these are absolute
these are not these are not the same
these are not the same thing your weight
might be a function of mass but your
weight your mass is going to be the same
regardless of where you go your weight
is a function of mass depending on
essentially the the the environmental
influences in the area what type of
objects are you near what type of
gravitational influences are there so
these are definitely not the same the
same thing
an object's mass can change depending on
its location this is absolutely false an
an object's mass cannot change depending
on its location whether i'm on earth or
i'm on the moon i will have the same
mass assuming that between the earth and
the moon i didn't use the restroom or
eat a hamburger or something
putting those aside or sweat i will have
the exact same mass maybe a better
example if i have two identical
books and i take one to the moon they
will have the same mass but their weight
will change so this one is absolutely
false an object's mass cannot change
depending on its location but this right
over here is true an object's weight can
change depending on its location so
those two books if you if they maybe
each of them has a one kilogram mass one
kilogram mass whether they're on earth
or whether in the whether they're on the
moon or whether they're on deep space
but their weight will change the force
of gravity on that book will be
different or on each of those books will
be different whether they are on earth
or whether they are on the moon it will
change based on the gravitational
influences so an object's weight can
definitely change depending on its
location so i'll put a little check mark
right over there
fourth statement weight can be measured
in kilograms and this is a bit of a
trick statement because
especially in the metric system if you
go to europe and if you ask someone how
much they weigh they will often give you
a number in terms of kilograms they will
say i weigh 50 kilograms and they're
even weighing machines that will give
you or claim to give you your weight in
kilograms but kilograms are not a
measure of weight kilograms are a
measure of mass
so kilograms are a measure of mass so
people actually should not be saying i
weigh 50 kilograms they should be saying
my mass is 50 kilograms or i have a mass
of 50 kilograms and those weighing
machines are actually trying to get your
mass somehow assuming that you know the
force the gravitational forces are
pretty constant across most of the
surface of the earth changes in altitude
aren't going to make that big of a
difference weight if we're in the metric
system would be measured in newtons
weight is a force so weight is going to
be measured this right over here weight
is going to be measured in
is going to be measured in newtons
so you would take whatever mass you have
whatever your actual mass is multiply it
times the gravitational field in that
vicinity of the earth and you will get
the pull of gravity on that object which
is going to be measured in newtons but
this statement right over here is not
true weight is not measured in kilograms
no matter what anyone might tell you
and then the fifth statement two objects
can have the same mass and different
weights well this once again is the
example of the two books i can have two
object two books they have exactly
both have a mass of one kilogram but i
could take them to different planets and
then their weights will change depending
on what planets they one of the books
goes to versus the other or even i could
take one to mount everest and i could
take one to a very low point on earth
and they'll have a very minor relative
in the whole scheme of things distance
to the center of earth and there'll be a
slight change in the gravitational field
so they will have slightly ever so
slightly different weights but they will
have the exact same mass so statement 3
and statement 5 are absolutely true so i
will
i will circle them
i will circle them in
in
green